We were doing something on auto painting.
And companies, it turns out the process of color matching is actually non - trivial; it's a very...
...complicated thing to do.
And all of the paint manufacturers have a very rigorous, specific way;...
...a set of steps that you're supposed to go through to get a perfect match.
Well, when we got out there and started watching guys painting cars,...
...what we saw was they weren't paying any attention to all those steps at all.
They were taking every shortcut in the book, figuring they could get it close enough.
Why do they do that? Well, most of them are paid based on piecework.
So, faster is better and close enough is good enough...
...and our client was totally unaware of this.
There's a big disconnect that you could only learn sometimes through observational techniques.
Now, there are a lot of pros and a lot of cons to ethnography.
One of the difficulties is that the interviews are very costly and very time - consuming.
And as a result, it's impossible to get the kind of sample size...
...that many product developers feel they need to do...
...a good voice of the customer or a good discovery study.
So, they tend to rely on relatively small sample sizes.
The other big problem that everybody contends with is the issue that has come to be known as...
...the Hawthorne effect.
And in a nutshell what that is, is the notion that observation alters behavior.
For instance, you would see this all the time in a construction site...
...where when the workers know that they're being observed, everybody is going exactly by the book.
They're wearing their hard hat and following all the safety rules.
And the minute the observers go away, they go back to,...
..."sometimes we wear the hard hat, sometimes we don't, sometimes we saw a board over our knee"...
...which is a real no no; it's a great way to cut into your leg.
And so, it's almost impossible to filter that out in an ethnography.
It simply is a kind of a fact that a good researcher has to try to contend with along the way.